and the mug like this is functional the
um
the logos on either side and the best
part about it
is it is it holds what you put in it you
know what i mean
no leaks and and also it holds the
temperature it's not one of the unit
and it's it goes you know goes straight
up doesn't go out
so it it holds the temperature rich
let's say i have a handful of reese's
pieces
with the cup hold those it would
definitely hold that okay we've been
talking to our radiologists rejoining us
right here
uh we've been uh we've been talking
about um uh
our merchandise store rich
eisenstore.com we're selling a bunch of
stuff
because i own i own this i own my
business i own the show now
we're here on peacock nbc sports on
peacock just
trying to keep things going and uh my
next guest
is is owning his own world content is
king
he's got his own brand after many many
many moons on espn
and um and he's joining us here to talk
about everything in the national
football league season
he's got his own podcast that's out
right now
um and here to talk about all that
with the grass green grass growing
underneath his feet
is trey wingo how are you trey richard
first of all it is
the light and and let me just say that's
the best part of waking up
is rich eisen in your company thank you
sir i appreciate that trey
now i gotta tell you my first job in
television
late eighties i was a page at nbc
and one of the first things they did
they had me with thirty rock was work
in the nbc store yes from the day after
thanksgiving till christmas eve without
a day off and we were pushing today show
mugs
golden girl t-shirts late night with
david letterman hats
so i appreciate the enthusiasm with
which you were selling those products so
were you the were you
the basis of kenneth the page troy did
you have the jacket
that's that was the job i mean i think
that they probably thought of other
people besides me
sure that was that was the first gig we
were given guided tours of the building
man
i was an intern for the cbs evening news
trey
when dan rather and connie chung hosted
it together
um and i was stuck on a desk answering
phones and people just complaining
because it was the summer of oj's
preliminary trial and they were
yeah they were live with dan and connie
and they were preempting the price is
right and all of these
soap operas and people are calling up
livid and that was my job
and then i would look up and i would
watch the intern with
the medical correspondent chief medical
correspondent at the time was dr bob
arnott if that name rings a bell
absolutely and his intern
was named melissa stark and she was
traveling all over the country and doing
actual work and she's
to this day lords that over me stinks
well listen see this this
always treat your interns with respect
that's true right because
you never know we're all sort of gophers
and interns ages you meet the same
people on the way up as you do on the
way down and real quickly
who was that that said reese's pieces
that would be tj jefferson rich eisen
show
social media grand maester okay
i you're the first person in the history
of the world
to pronounce that reese's pieces it's
risa's pieces man
[Laughter]
like where are you from that you say
reese's pizza
altoona pennsylvania that's how we say
having spent
nine months in allentown i get it now
that's on the other side of the street
let me let me turn this in a proper
direction
for all of us here okay let's place that
in the half forgotten history of the
rich eisen show trey how about that
[Music]
rich with a win why are you calling your
podcast half forgotten history
trey what's that real simple and thank
you for uh allowing me to talk about
that you're welcome
you know rich you do this long enough
and you hang around with guys
like you hang around with michael and
kurt and
all those guys and i've hung around with
you know brewski
and damien and ryan clark and stink and
a bunch of other people darren woodson
randy
moss half half the best stories
yes that you hear never make air
they're all the stuff you talk about
when you're in the green room before the
camera and the lights go on
yes or the mic is on yes or when you're
out to dinner at the super bowl and
someone drops a bomb story on you
over a cocktail or two and you're like
man we got to tell those stories yes
so the whole premise of the show is
thanks to our sponsors state farm
mcdonald's and makers mark
look at you we're we're chopping it up
we're just sitting down talking ball
about some of the greatest things in the
greatest moments in the game
that i know you probably know but not
everybody else knows
so there has to still be stories with uh
with you just
mentioning you know the golden arches
and things like that you still have to
keep uh
under wraps i imagine oh yeah yeah
we had we had darren on with aaron
woodson yeah i said what's the story you
can tell about the cowboys of the
nineties without
getting yourself or your best friends
arrested yes
well we totally started the cowboys of
the 90s in social media
can you imagine god trey do we tell
everybody do we tell
kevin with the kevin barlow story that
mooch once told off the air we actually
got on the air because we actually had
matt willig the
player uh turned actor uh
you've seen many times in the old uh
what's in your wallet commercials the
capital one commercial plays one of the
vikings in it
anyway yeah i'll tell this story what
the hell yeah it's a new audience on
peacock too they might not know it of
course
so much told this story this is one of
those half forgot the one of the stories
that you can't tell on the air
and mooch would never tell it refused to
tell he wouldn't tell it because he's
you know above board but he has told the
story right kevin barlow the old
running back of the san francisco 49ers
was
homesick a lot and he was on his cell
phone all the time and one time
kevin barlow comes into the office
to complain about the fact that matt
willig and the offensive lineman
were so upset by him being on his cell
phone all the time they confiscated it
from him
and then stuck it where matt willis this
son does not shine on matt willig does
that make sense to you
it does well actually that's what that's
why they invented phone soap by the way
yes indeed
well i guess the the the proper
preposition for it would be
up which is where they stuck it and um
and i told i told the story on the air
had willing tell the story mooch was so
upset
that this story was told on the air
especially since the punchline of the
story that was confirmed
is that mooch demanded willig
after demanding if it was true or not
confirming the truth of this
sordid tale uh made willie give the
phone back to barlow
who was 60 seconds later seen making a
phone call please tell me he had handy
wipes
i don't believe uh i don't know mid-90s
that's the story
and i'm sticking to it that was the
story so you should have mooch on your
show
half boot chart he is filled with those
stories oh
i plan on it gosh how are you otherwise
trey cause
when i left espn um susie was out here
working in los angeles
you know covering the lakers i went to
an all-star game people asked me if i
was okay
uh i said yeah i'm i can fog up a mirror
for you if you want
so um how are you um
doing trey look i'm i'm i'm really good
and of course you are i just it's fine
it is kind of funny right because it's
it's a job
it's it's not your life right and i
i told them about a year and a half ago
that i just didn't think
doing the morning show was my long-term
aspiration
and they asked me to do it and i said
sure they we had a three-year contract
and i said absolutely i will do this for
three years and then
we'll see and i knew pretty soon into it
that it just wasn't what i wanted to do
so uh i went to them in may or june of
2019 and said look i just want to give
you guys a heads up because i don't
leave you hanging and i don't want to be
like a month before the deal is up
saying i want to do something else
because i feel like that would
me being a bad employee so i just wanted
to give you guys as much time as
possible that when my deal's up i'm
gonna want to do something else
and that apparently
was the beginning of my demise
i only laughed i was being a good guy
about it oh uh whatever
no i i as i'm as i'm saying you know
look
um you what an incredible run you had
man
i had i think only half as long a run as
you did i was there for seven years
and so you know um wait how long were
you there
seven that's it seven years dude i was
there 23. i know
i thought you were there much longer no
i was there for look you know
um i was there for seven years 96 to 03
and i've been with nfl network this is
my 18th season with nfl network
that doesn't even seem possible for me
but that's so cool man well just look at
my hairline trey and it's possible
well i could say something but i won't i
will say look at my hair because
when you and i worked together my hair
was the same color
and that has a lot of you no no no you
no
no no you've always had like this steve
martin look with your hair
trey like your hair has always been
prematurely gray in a way i
from my recollection early 30s it
started to turn funny story steve martin
actually attended high school in waco
texas
where of course i went to baylor
university also that's
right okay so let's let's get into who's
the best team
is it the chiefs what do you think let's
talk some balls right let's talk
until somebody runs out the clock on
that dude in the playoffs right
why would we not say they're the best
team i mean we saw it three times in the
postseason last year double digit leads
doesn't matter 24 points doesn't matter
down 11 in the super bowl with eight
minutes to play third and fifteen
doesn't matter so there may be a team
that's better but until someone beats
that team
i don't see it who's the team that can
do it though
i've got i've got i said one in week
four and then i got off them and now i'm
thinking about the bills again
i think so the first the way josh allen
played in september in early october
made me think i don't know defensively
you know
uh obviously trey white put him on
tyreek hill hope for the best and think
that and hope that you can get
some sort of jalen ramsay-like erasure
uh but then there's the rest of the team
that might be the issue and
allen could give them problems uh the
running game concerns me
yeah i think the most honest way to
answer that question i could name
five teams that could do it yes but i
think at the end of the day do i think
any of them
will do it and for me the answer is no
absolutely josh ellen by the way has
been on fire the last
three or four weeks he they could do it
pittsburgh
but you know three times out of ten
could probably do it
uh maybe the saints with they meet in
the super bowl could probably do it
but all of those to me are assuming
variables and possibilities the most
realistic
outcome for me is what we saw last
february in miami
and i believe that the chiefs are going
to be the first team to repeat since the
pat said it in 38 and 39 super bowls so
let me give you one off the books here
off the board to use the old joker's
wild phrase okay
and a triple oh it's into triple how
about this one okay
the teams that gave the chiefs the most
problems in the playoff run last year as
we know
tennessee gave him a nice scare in the
afc championship game
right and obviously the san francisco
49ers were up in the fourth quarter
so what do they have they had a running
game
that was a prodigious defense correct
and also
a quarterback that could play action you
and if with
not making the mistake beat you deep
right even though i know jimmy g missed
that shot to emmanuel's
it was wide open so who's got who's got
a really
stout running game and line and defense
and quarterback that's not making
mistakes right now what about the
cleveland browns
what about them well by the way i think
that's your answer you can move on if
you just want that side to be your
answer but listen i
the browns have been a great story and
kevin stefanski has been
phenomenal and he's done a great job at
first i thought you were talking about
indianapolis when you're talking about
no
i i i i don't know they've been way too
inconsistent for me and
and philly riv philly riv you know when
you're pushing 40 and you've got a
toe injury that needs surgery i think
that that's
that's an expiration date that's that's
approaching quite frankly
correct 2020 correct look the cleveland
browns are entering what we've what
we've really seen from cleveland
is a complete evolution over the last
two plus seasons right because
when they sort of came on the scene in
baker's rook a year
he broke peyton manning's rookie
touchdown record right
and now that team has completely turned
to 180 and involved into a run first
team and we saw let's go back to week
three the regular season monday night
game
kansas city goes to baltimore baltimore
marches right down the field
takes off like i think six seven eight
minutes off the clock
they stall in the red zone kick a field
goal they give the ball back to the
chiefs and i think they took two minutes
to score a touchdown
so the the problem for cleveland in my
mind going up against and could they do
it again
i give they're one of a few teams i give
a punchers chance no question about it
but you have to sustain a drive if
you're a run first team for a long
period of time with no mistakes
and then you have to cash in those
drives whereas when you're playing
kansas city
all right we went three and out we won't
go three and out three times in a row
it's much easier to score the way the
chiefs are going to score
than the way the browns have sort of set
themselves up to score
in terms of long sustained drives work
you have to make sure
you don't get behind the chains there's
not a holding penalty there's not a
illegal formation there's not one drop
pass you know what i mean right
so you don't believe in the brown so so
that side that started the whole
spiel here is your answer i i'm not
going to believe it
until someone does it that's that's just
sorry they just did it against the
titans
i guess so they did it against the
titans if they do it against the ravens
right and then they do it against the
giants those are their next two
nationally televised games
by the way what's more 2020 than flexing
out of cowboys niners you're gonna say
the cowboys and niners are out the
browns and giants are in
right what's more 2020 than that right
nothing but
but here's the here's the thing right
you just talked about those two games
the ravens aren't the ravens from a year
ago and
the problem with baltimore is they sort
of believed okay
this one thing we did better than
anybody arguably ever last year
we can do it again which is run for 212
yards a game
and that's never going to happen so the
problem with the ravens is they they
base
in my mind they base 20 20 on okay let
if we just do that again
then the other things will fall into
place well that thing was so singularly
unique and and out of whack
with norms that was the flaw in the
ointment in my
in my thought process that you can't
rely on something so
incredibly outside the ordinary to
happen time and time again
so uh in the nfc who do you like before
i let you go trade which one
yeah who comes out well listen i said
all along this year and i don't know how
you felt about it but because of the off
season where we didn't have one
right what was really going to help
would be a team that had a sustained
coaching staff in place with a
quarterback in place and a proven system
that works
and to me that's still new orleans and
they sean payton think about this rich
and i know you know this but like
over the last two years they are eight
no with their backup quarterback well
nine and five
last year with teddy bridgewater 3-0
this year would take some of that right
exactly and
that to me it shows you what the team is
about and what the culture is about
there
and i think that it's going to be the
chiefs and more than likely it's going
to be the saints and that could be a
super bowl for the ages yeah i was
counting
the win against uh philadelphia that i
think is coming up although
i've never seen anything like that man
uh jalen hurts could actually win this
game i i shouldn't just
chalk it up right here to uh well
needed to do something but carson went
to the president for the off season now
you can't fix him now
i don't know man you know what i mean
like so
yeah uh what do what do you think what's
more likely
wence or cam getting back to mvp
status what's more likely who's the
second name i'm sorry thank you jam
you know you got two former mvps within
just
well i guess you know obviously once was
an mvp but he was playing like one
i mean he would have been hurt
so here's the thing about the cam
situation like
they're throwing for what like last
night he threw for a decent amount but
over the last three games i think he
threw for 76 yards
again that's hard to that's a hard thing
to sustain
i believe that once because he's younger
and we've seen that sort of
performance from him in the past i think
that went
if you can fix this part of this is
mental right i know people have been
telling me he still messed up with the
whole nick foles thing
and then you you get sacked what 10 10
straight games at least three sacks
taken down over 50 times already i don't
care who you are like sam darnold got
roasted for i'm seeing ghosts every
quarterback sees ghosts if they get hit
that often see tom brady in the afc
championship game at 2015 in denver
he saw ghosts in that game you hit any
quarterback enough
things change david carr never survived
his rookie year in 2002 when he was sex
76 times i mean you you can't do it so
carson is a is a reboot in the off
season so
are are we on a cadence for half
forgotten history is it
a certain number of times a week or
catches catch monday wednesday friday
uh we just dropped our second uh episode
with emmitt smith today where he talks
about
how he thought his marketing team had
jinxed him and the halftime speech that
turned around super bowl 28 when they
were down 13-6
and we got three more episodes dropping
next week okay and i like the logo with
the football it's the sans of the
hourglass very well done trey i like the
whole thing thank you
i appreciate that you are welcome um um
if you if you're
if you need somebody uh on the show i'm
more than happy to
um sit in and do whatever you need
if that's something that you're
interested in sir i want to do those
things we sort of have a
long story short we have a commitment to
do a certain thing for a while but then
after that we're going to be sort of
branching out into those kind of things
and
brother you and i could tell some
stories on our own exactly right
exactly right trey anytime uh congrats
on your pod and everything else going on
with you
thanks rich always a pleasure happy
holidays and say it with me everybody
reese's pieces reese's this is peace
there you go thank you very much
trey wingo right here you go that's trey
wingo at wingo z on twitter still
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here